so we believe your team was one of the
first to use the red camera is that
right yeah back in back in two thousand
seven the red one came out I was on the
waiting list back you know 2006 we were
out of nab and it was like okay put your
name on the waiting list put a thousand
dollars in deposit and you're gonna wait
for a camera that has 4k resolution it
sounds a bit unknown but we did you know
I was part of that first thousand that
was on the waiting list and in 2007 on
that fall they finally released the
first twenty five cameras or something
like that and we got to shoot out on the
bonneville salt flats on a short film
call you uni we were working with red
number 19 you know out there and we did
a short film on the red camera those are
those early days but yeah in 2008 we got
one of the red cameras and then went out
and shot this project out of burning man
so you purchased the camera you put the
deposit down and you purchased it yeah
yeah we were red number 98 and so from
the behind-the-scenes footage that I
watched which is absolutely beautiful by
the way it shows that you've protected
the camera with like plastic because of
these whiteout days can you tell us what
was involved what's a whiteout day why
protect it like that yeah well I mean
you want to protect any kind of camera
out there the dust storms will just
happen and there's 40 mile an hour winds
and the dust is not like any dust you've
ever experienced its alkaline dry
lakebed dust I mean it's not sand it's
not dirt it's it's a very sticky
material and so yeah it gets on your
fingers and your fingers touch things
and all of a sudden you have it on your
lenses and on your camera and so yeah we
we ended up gaff taping over a bunch of
the camera ports and then we had a
protective plastic bag that sometimes
we'd throw the camera into if it was
like complete whiteout but um yeah this
stuff this stuff blows into cracks you
didn't know exist
it the dust out there and if it gets in
those cracks is that what can be done to
fix it or nothing can be done it's the
balance of like are you going to take a
camera out there and protect it the
whole time and not get that much access
to your camera or you're going to go out
there with a camera and just say well
it's just a camera i can replace it it's
a fine balance and and we had three red
cameras out there we had ten little
pocket HD cameras out there and we had a
couple digital SLRs shooting time-lapse
and we did our best we have the digital
SLR covered as best we could we have the
small pocket cameras kinda not protected
but the red cameras were kind of
protected it's tough i was out there
shooting a couple years later back in
2010 in 2011 for another project and
destroyed the camera destroyed the red
so it's it's an expensive piece of gear
to have to deal with how did that happen
it was just a dust I think you know it
gets inside and even though the Reds are
incredibly protected especially now with
a new epoch cameras they're just
workhorses I mean beef they these things
have been in conditions like burning man
that are just unbelievable crazy
temperatures freezing temperatures
altitude everything they're just amazing
and I think you know I just push it to
limits and we had to replace I think one
of the processing boards inside got
wrecked so so with the three red cameras
that you took out there were they all
purchased or you rented two of them and
purchased one um basically i worked with
other filmmakers my friend clay a new
york-based filmmaker came out with his
camera and then another guy came out
with his so we had we had three total
you